[Music]
thank you
Tucker uh I think it's fair to say
you've encountered quite a lot of
criticism in recent days because as far
as I can figure out you are the only
mainstream host who is skeptical of the
idea that President Biden needs to
interfere militarily if Vladimir Putin
invades Ukraine and for that you have
been called a Russian spy a Russian
asset uh Democratic politicians have
said that you are your viewers are
calling them up to tell them that you're
on Russia's side how do you answer this
charge that you are on the side of an
evil authoritarian
with the chuckle
um but what's interesting is the
presumption in the United States is that
it's you know terrible to be an asset of
Russia but entirely acceptable to be an
asset of Ukraine and and many of course
in Washington are the president's own
son worked for a Ukrainian company and
the president himself was deeply
enmatched in the internal politics of
Ukraine when he was vice president and
of course till today
um and I'm not sure why that's better
you know no one in the United States
ought to be an agent of a foreign power
or promoting foreign interests at the
expense of America's interests I mean in
a democracy it's very simple the
government exists to serve the people
who put it in power by voting
and your foreign policy ought to reflect
that which is to say your foreign policy
ought to serve the interests of the
country now if it's ancillary effects or
improve the lives of others then that's
that's certainly great and virtuous but
if its primary goal is to
serve the interests of other countries
or their populations then it's by
definition legitimate I mean that's the
you know that's the role of church
groups and ngos and you know there are
plenty of humanitarian organizations but
the US military United States Department
the White House the US Congress even our
media
exist for the benefit of the United
States period and they've lost sight of
that and that's the problems the
argument I'm making against
intervening between Ukraine and Russia
and we already have by the way we've
said billions in what we're now calling
lethal weapons
as opposed to what I suppose but um
missile systems and small arms and all
kinds of stuff
to Ukraine into neighboring countries
you know we're already funding a proxy
war
so why would we be doing that I mean is
there a vital American interest that
serves perhaps there is I haven't heard
anyone explain it and you sort of know
if they go immediately to you're working
for Vladimir Putin or something I have
like a limited interest in Vladimir
Putin I've never been to Russia I don't
speak Russian much less Ukrainian it's
just not a part of the world that is
captured by interest but even if it had
to answer my question
right I mean like what is the vital
interest at stake and of course they
they can't answer it so they go ad
hominem immediately to me that's a very
obvious sign
of their weakness if you become
hysterical when someone asks you why
you're doing something then maybe you're
doing the wrong thing well perhaps
there's a certain insecurity about NATO
uh and particularly among in Britain I
know uh there's a strong desire to
sustain NATO even though the sort of
primary purpose of NATO uh to win the
Cold War has gone uh and do you think
there's an argument a legitimate
argument to be said that if we allow uh
Putin to expand into Eastern Europe into
non-nato Powers then he will be
buttering buffering up against uh NATO
powers that we are committed by treaty
to support and America is committed by
treaty to support so it it puts Russia
and the West at a sort of trigger point
that they aren't at the moment
okay well I I mean I guess but that
would be a voluntary trigger I assume I
mean I think it's important given that
the Soviet Union collapsed when I was on
my honeymoon that was 30 years ago I
mean the full collapse happened in
August of 1991 that was the point it was
my father worked for the US government
waging the Cold War so that was at the
very center of our family's
conversations every night at the very
same moment that many of these now
Russia Hawks are making excuses for the
Soviets I should point out irony of
ironies but any case it was a secular
regime then it's a regime that
subsidizes the Orthodox church now so
maybe that's the difference I just to
guess but but in any case at that point
you know you'd think someone would say
okay we have all these post-war
institutions that have I think very
effectively maybe even valiantly serve
their purpose they kept the Soviets from
invading Western Europe that's great I
was always for that always for NATO but
at this point what is their purpose
maybe we repurpose them we recite we
have a standing army called NATO so
maybe we do something new with it but no
one ever or kind of articulated what the
new purpose is
and that's a huge problem if you have I
mean this is a thing something that you
know anyone who covers Washington where
I was for 35 years sees every single day
these zombie institutions marching
forward toward what no one will ever say
their original purpose has either
disappeared
where they failed to achieve it they've
been proven ineffective at doing what
they were designed to do but they
continue because they're well funded
that's fine if it's the Head Start
program which was designed in 1965 to
raise the IQ of poor kids it didn't work
but we still have it but if you have an
army if you have a military alliance
called NATO
I don't know that could be really
disruptive unless you have a clear goal
I mean this used to be prerequisite for
all military action define articulate
the goal make it very clear to all
participants this is what we're
attempting to do
Imperial Japan we will not stop until
you prosper and we accept your
unconditional surrender they wouldn't we
dropped the atom bomb on two other
cities okay got it now you could agree
or disagree with what we did but the
goal was never in doubt was
unconditional surrender so what is the
goal of NATO exactly
to protect Ukraine that's not a member I
mean the whole thing is so
so crazy and childish I anyway you see
the point if I mean if if as some people
suggest one day you might be if you were
president of the United States would you
say let's scrap NATO
you know as it can as an instinctive
conservative I'm against breaking things
without a good reason so you have I
think the first thing I would do with
assess your students we have this thing
we have this military Alliance it's
awfully well funded
and awfully well-armed relatively
speaking and is there something useful
we could do with that and I and I think
it would be
worth pausing I have not I've been
thinking about this for you know fairly
intently for four years since Putin
three and a half years met with
Trump in Helsinki I was there and this
was this was a big topic like what's the
point of NATO and I have not met anyone
who could explain how we could do
something useful with NATO
um does anyone sincerely believe that
Western Europe is at risk
of being invaded by Putin well if it is
then Western European nations which I
think we at this point can trust to have
weapons
should defend themselves I mean that's
the idea of the nation-state you defend
your own interests you have a vested
interests you have what we call skin in
the game and you want to defend it if
it's worth something to you and that
system has kind of worked fairly well
well I mean I don't want to sound like I
don't want to sound like a hawk because
I don't think I am but I mean I suppose
the theory would be
if let's say Putin somehow takes over
Ukraine which again is is doubtful uh he
would then be up against the Baltic
states some of which are uh some NATO
members so what how would you how would
you deal with that would you say that if
he invades a Baltic state does that
become a difference I'm not sure I would
deal with I mean as from the American
look I'm an American I have no other
passport I've got four kids four dogs
and a house I'm not going anywhere so
from my perspective is wholly American
and I think every country has a
different perspective that's why I was
for brexit you know and each country
should be able to represent its own
perspective on the world stage that's
like a baseline view for me so from an
American perspective I would say is it
you know given the competing nature of
interests
is it in the top tier of interests to
prevent Russian expansion in Eastern
Europe I mean it's not something you'd
wish you want free people to live in
Freedom on the other hand the freedom of
people threatened the world over their
ongoing border disputes in Africa the
continent that I'm actually interested
in that have been you know going on
grinding on causing the deaths of
literally millions for decades and you
know that's sad nobody wants it to be
the case but is it in our interest to
physically prevent it or try to we also
have a terrible record of actually
affecting the desired outcomes we just
withdrew from Afghanistan this fall
after the longest war in American
history and rather than pausing to ask
why didn't that go as expected what are
the mistakes we made what are the
assumptions that led to those mistakes
were on to you know contemplating an
invasion of Russia during winter because
that works anyway this is very
interesting I would ask the question
like the the clearly the threats to the
United States and the uh our interests
global trade routes energy
pure like military power relative uh
relative military power comes from China
of course
and so to the extent that you are
focused on another region given the size
of our military our attention span the
limits of our budget you are detracting
from that and so the question is is it
worth it and being American we're not
trained to think that way we imagine
everything is a possibility the world's
a menu of Endless Possibilities we can
do all of it
but the truth is we can't never have
been able to there are limits of you
know physics and money and in reality
that impose on you and so of course I
wish Latvia the best I would feel sad if
Latvia ever lost its autonomy to the
extent it actually has autonomy as a new
member but whatever
I would say to myself you know that's
sad is it but is intervening given the
realistic possibilities of doing what we
want to do worth it given that that
would detract from the real problems
which are East not Eastern Europe but
Far East so that's how I would think
about it I think that's a pretty
moderate
sensible realistic way to think about
anything I don't think that's radical I
certainly don't think it's taking
Putin's side I have no I have no special
interest in any of this I only care
about my country
what's interesting you mentioned in
China because I mean there's been a lot
of talk in foreign policy circles about
the Pacific pivot over the last 20 years
in America and how America's strategic
Focus now has to move to the Pacific
rather than to Europe the Middle East uh
and Eastern Europe uh and of course the
Pacific pivot does actually challenge
China I mean it does challenge China's
ambition so it does presumably suit
China for America to be focused on uh
the Ukraine because it means they care a
little bit less about what China's doing
in say the South China Sea or something
like that needless to say
so and you could you know look I'm not
alleging any conspiracy here I do think
there is a feature of human nature
that causes and I think it's innate that
causes people when confronted with an
unsolvable problem to turn to something
else to occupy their minds and anyone
who's been I mean this is relevant to
your viewers or journalists anyone's
ever been on deadline for say a magazine
piece will find himself sorely tempted
to rearrange his books by offer because
it's it's another problem to work on as
you ignore the problem that confronts
you that you actually can't solve China
is a problem this is very hard for the
United States to solve it's not clear
How We Do solve that problem but by
problem I mean
you know sort of giving hegemony over
the world to a country that doesn't
believe anything really that we believe
it would be a massive change in the way
the world operates in the way that we in
the United States live and the way that
you and Great Britain live I mean having
China in charge of the world would be
very different from what we have now
that's a huge concern a legitimate
concern I think
um and we're not meaningfully dealing
with it and I think you know part you
often your people on the right say well
that's because they're all taking money
from China well yes that's true our
former Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright was like a by the way but
got rich as so many have been but you
know got rich effectively making China's
case to the American Business Community
many others in our diplomatic War have
done the same so that's that's a
straight up sellout Hollywood sells out
the NBA sells out they're controlled by
the Chinese government everyone knows
that but I think the deeper problem has
nothing to do with Commerce it just has
to do with the terrifying nature of this
threat
and our own fear that we can't actually
do anything about it so here's where I
would start
not that I make these decisions but it's
not a question of pivoting East China
has massive influence within our
hemisphere
go to any island in the Caribbean
including the American colonies there we
call them protectorates or Southern
Colonies Saint Croix Virgin Islands for
example all the infrastructure in San
Carlos built by China
what why would China be building the
airport
and the roads in Saint Croix and why are
they doing the same in Jamaica and Haiti
and virtually every population Center in
the Caribbean also true in South America
again
this is our hemisphere which for more
than 200 years we've said explicitly we
control we will not allow
you know world powers from across the
oceans to control you know anything of
meaning in our Hemisphere and yet they
are and this is being completely I never
heard anybody mention it I've just
noticed it from traveling a lot
so I would just start there and say you
know what is this about maybe it's
totally benign that they're building the
infrastructure in Bolivia maybe it's not
well also I mean if if you were
designing American global strategy you
would think if you were George Cannon or
something you would think
isolating China would be good therefore
splitting Russia off from China would be
good except for the fact that America's
rhetoric at the moment seems to be
driving Russia to and China together as
as quickly as possible what's and that
is of course the effect I I personally
believe it's one of the intended effects
but what's so fascinating to me and so
repugnant
is that clearly there are many people in
positions of power in the United States
who sincerely believe that we have more
in common with China and this government
than the government of Russia now this
is in no way a defense of the way the
Putin government operates you'll notice
I don't live there I don't care to I
feel sorry for Ed Snowden is stuck there
etc etc but
if we're being honest and we always
should be we have far more in common
with Russia than we have with China I
mean Russia is a Christian country no
it's not any kind of Evangelical country
or morally upright country I'm not right
but its culture is rooted in western
civilization which is another way of
saying we never say it but it's true
Christian
civilization and Christianity I mean
it's presuppositions are Christian
whether it lives up to them often it
doesn't the darkest period in Russian
history was the period when it ceased to
be Russia then became Soviet
and you know anyway you see the point so
for our leaders we're very familiar with
how both of those countries work to look
at the world and say you know we're on
China's side which is absolutely what
they're saying
reveals something horrifying about them
again that's you could say you know I
hate Putin I hate the way he runs that
government
but really compared to what I mean
that's the other thing compared to what
this is a nasty world
filled with you know genocidal lunatics
at the helm not simply of two or three
countries but of a lot of countries and
the only reason they're not committing
genocide is because I'm the power to but
there are a lot of bad people in charge
always have been so to decide that Putin
is the worst of the lot like you're
lying actually or you're totally
ignorant
well you'll you'll bring up of
Christianity and Western culture brings
up another accusation that is often made
against you which is that you are
arousing the forces of ethno-nationalism
uh how do you respond when people say
that to you ethno net I mean that's one
of those phrases that the sort of
half-wits in charge of the Atlantic
magazine throw around without thinking
about
ethnonationalism I don't know I don't
even know what my ethnicity is I'm like
half Swedish I have English I guess it's
not of great interest to me I can tell
you that I'm an American I don't think
of nothing in terms I wasn't raised that
way at all
um and I still don't and I resist all
pressure too pressure mostly from the
left to categorize myself and everybody
is a member of some Community or racial
group I hate that and I will never
participate in it so but I would say
what's so interesting is that the same
people who are saying you know
opposing war with Russia over Ukraine is
ethnonationalism or simultaneously
making the case the Ukraine is for
ukrainians
and the Russians have have no right to
enter so our country we had two million
immigrants unauthorized illegal without
documents whatever you call them come
into this country in the last calendar
year 2021 2 million that's like four
times the size of the city of Boston
that's a massive number of people okay
even in a country of 345 million so a
lot of people unprecedented
and the pre the justification for this
is well borders are racist people have a
right to go whatever they want in search
of a better life
here I'm looking at tens of thousands of
Russian citizens massed on the Ukrainian
border hoping to get in for a better
life
and I'm seeing world leaders say no
you're not allowed to do that Ukraine is
for ukrainians I mean speaking of
ethnonationalism why is this if we can
import thousands of Haitians illegally
why is it such a lift for the ukrainians
to you know let several thousand
Russians in
obviously I'm joking sort of I mean of
course I'm joking
but I also think like that's that's a
ridic I mean speaking of ethno Nationals
what's the largest ethno-nationalist
nation in the world well it's their
closest Allied China
is an ethno State it's run by and for
the Chinese what do you think the
weakers are getting so much trouble why
do you think that you know the
Mongolians and the Tibetans because
they're not hung Chinese so look I I'm
not you know you run your country as you
want I'm not really much of a judger
actually I judge my own country because
I live here
but the same people you know Bill
crystals like he's like an idiot no
nationalism fascism okay got it got it
built a guy who couldn't even run a
small circulation magazine is like I'm
in charge of American foreign policy
think about what you're saying I mean
it's like it's it's ridiculous and so
there are many ridiculous people I'm
ridiculous sometimes I get it I have a
high tolerance for Ridiculousness it's
the seriousness with which ludicrous
people are taken that really scares me
we have a big important country you
can't allow dumb people to act stupidly
without you know reacting to it it's
like what uh it really freaks me out how
mediocre our leadership class is not
just that they're wrong but they're like
low IQ it's like Bill crystal is
considered an intellectual really on the
basis of what
what you know do you do you now
deliberately uh organize your program to
trigger their rage I mean for instance
no no no I I don't I mean one thing I do
do I I don't and by the way if I'm being
honest
you know I don't have a great sense of
their rage because I don't you know I
don't like the internet it hasn't made
me smarter you know I really I make an
affirmative effort to turn off all the
garbage devices I don't own a TV but I
have an iPad and a phone you know that's
my whole Electronics right here and I
turned that stuff off at night and I
read books
you know nothing nothing crazy but I
read you know non-fiction books at night
and so I don't I just don't like I don't
think the internet has made us wiser or
even better informed
um and so I don't go on like social
media I'm not on Twitter reading about
myself or whatever so I don't really
know did you like people say and I'm not
that interested if if there's something
important someone I love will tell me
and I'll listen carefully but like what
if David from is mad like I worked with
David from for six years I know David
from really well yeah David Frum is mad
at me I mean fine you know what I mean I
I don't care why would I care did you
miss I hope you didn't miss uh sorry to
move off global politics completely the
reaction to your Eminem Eminem's segment
on social media it's so funny you said
it yeah I missed it completely and the
only reason I know anything about it is
because one of my producers called me
today and said this morning and said
let's do a follow-up on that Eminem
segment which I wrote in and I'm not
exaggerating like six minutes I mean it
was nothing
80 words in that let's explain to
British viewers what that was that uh
that something happened with eminent one
of the M Ms that it made them there was
a certainly Eminem Eminem Mars the
company that makes M M's which are in
case you don't have them in the UK
chocolate candies yeah I'm as you can
probably tell I'm a big I love candy
anyway so they come out and they're like
okay our cartoon characters which have
been a feature of our advertising for a
long time and they're just like little
round chocolate candies with legs
um we have realized through some deep
reflection that they're sexist and the
female characters are wearing like sexy
boots and now because women matter and
women in leadership are so important
we're going to put them in frumpy flat
sold shoes
and so like okay again I mean personally
a supporter of the M M's company I mean
I single-handedly keep their stock price
high so I'm not against M Ms but I just
made the point that like women can be in
leadership and still wear sexy boots
there's like nothing there's nothing
inherently contradictory about that you
can have women who are still feminine or
whatever leading things and I just I was
just mocking I was just mocking it I was
just joking I mean I you know uh but
apparently people got all
got all exercised
fine with me well I think from uh ethno
nationalism to Candy I think we've we've
covered quite a lot the thing is can I
just say one thing I just always think
this I do have some pretty far out views
on a couple of different things but
they're not related to anything
political you know I have really strong
views about nature or whatever
um that are not mainstream views however
my views on like race or sex or foreign
policy or like completely moderate
middle of the road you know 10 years ago
My Views were not even interesting
enough to mention yes and My Views
really haven't changed so it's just so
funny to be like this radical Putin
apologist racist
I'm more I'm much more conventional than
that what is your most far out View
I hate drywall
I I really don't like a natural building
materials I really believe in wood and
I'm an extremist on the subject and I
won't live in or spend any time in a
room whose walls are covered with
drywall which is like paper covered
gypsum yeah and it's a very conventional
Building Material because it's cheap and
easy to install but it's disgusting and
it's
sucks the life out of you it's it's just
innovating to be in a room covered with
travel so I just won't you know I won't
it's not more expensive to panel a room
with say Pine boards like the one I'm in
right now and so I do I'm not spending
any time in a room with drywall or
overhead lighting or anything
fluorescent like why would I do that I I
really believe in natural building
materials Aesthetics are really
important to me nature is really
important to me and so I'm just not
going to do it you know I'm never going
to stay in like a hotel room if I can
help it I don't I don't want you so
um
as you probably know that is your
fascistic ethnic nationalism expressing
yourselves well it's funny like I'm
architecture really matters to me and
when we were in Hungary last summer I
gave a speech I never write anything
down so she's giving a speech and I just
launched into this thing about
architecture because I really care about
it and whatever it's not you know I like
pretty architecture that elevates the
human spirit and not
sort of grotesque steel and glass
architecture that crushes the human
spirit I mean it's that simple it's not
I have no complex or brilliant views on
this at all they're very very normal
views but I really really mean it so I
give this speech and like David from
what he said to me it's like oh he's
Albert Speer he cares about architect
uh Tucker Coulson thank you so much for
coming on spectator TV thank you Freddie
it's great to see you please come on
again and uh yeah good luck with
everything
[Music]
thank you